welcome everybody to another edition of
ask Evan episode number four we're going
to get to your questions on how to help
grow your business so let's jump right
in first up Gregory groves who wrote in
this a question when your tips is to
work for someone go find a job with
someone I respect even if it's to
volunteer which is good advice but one
concern I have is what if I don't have
time to do that I'm married with a young
son and I'm already a small business
owner I run a personal training group
training business so I just don't have
any time to do this any advice so mala
success is one of the best the best
fastest ways to grow your business and
it always surprises me when
entrepreneurs say you don't have enough
time to do this I don't have time to do
that and and it makes sense you know
you're an entrepreneur fine you have
your family got your son I have a family
I have a son if something is important
to you then you have to make time to do
it how important is learning from
someone who's already done it is your
business growing are you having a lot of
success in it are you just at a certain
level and you're plateauing and you're
not getting the kind of income you want
from it you got to figure that out for
yourself right mentorship is one of the
most important things that you could do
for your business so you either make
time for it or not and it's going to be
the same thing for anything important in
your life right if your wife is
important to you are you going to say
I'm too busy with all this other stuff I
don't have time for you that's going to
lead to a divorce pretty quickly right
so big things this is exercise that that
I forget which consultant does it but
you have a bucket and then you have big
rocks little rocks and then sand and if
you put the sand in first and the Little
Rock's than the big rock it doesn't fit
it overflows and that's that's how most
people live their life and they don't
they don't have space for the big rocks
anymore we're what you want to do put
the big rocks in first then put in the
Little Rock's and then put in the same
and they'll all find their way to make
it into that bucket properly that's we
need to do with your business that's we
need to do with your life so is getting
mentorship important to you is it a big
rock give us a big rock you try to put
it on last it's not going to happen
you're going to feel stressed out
overwhelmed just like you do now if it
is important if it is part of what you
see is an important part of your
then put it in first put your rock put
your wife put your business whatever
your big rocks that's in there and then
you put in more okay and the little
things will work themselves out on top
of that I just like to say that you know
the mentorship they're learning from
somebody doesn't always have to come
from working with them one-on-one I've
learned a lot from reading biographies
from watching YouTube videos from
learning from people in my own time
reading books you know I consider Donald
Trump and Steve Jobs and Richard Branson
AP Giannini to be some of my mentors and
I've never met them and some of them are
dead and they continue to inspire and
motivate me and so you can also learn
from others and imagine what it would
like to be with them by consuming the
media that they create on top of going
out and working from somebody working
for somebody who's close to you okay
next up we're hopping over to Twitter
question coming in from ad tour westland
who writes to say thanks Evan Carmichael
for being so down the earth and helping
us entrepreneurs you work 20 hours a
week what is your number one time
management tip so I have five main time
management tips but you're asking for my
number one so I'm going to get just to
that one and that's eliminate you are
doing too much man you were doing too
much in your business and it's not
yielding enough results you have to be
the CEO of your business you need to
focus on what you do best you should be
walking to your office walk into your
bedroom wherever it is that you have
your office the building a home off is
the basement the garage the street star
box wherever your business is operating
from you want to walk there asking
yourself what's the most value that I
could bring to my business today and
chances are whatever the answer to that
question is you're not currently doing
it because you have too much other crap
in your life things that you think are
important that aren't things that you
think are important that aren't yielding
enough results what are you the best in
the world at and how can you bring that
to your business today and eliminate the
rest number one tip okay next up Justin
the think link champion who wrote in to
say hey Evan I watch a lot of your
videos i really love
all your videos you have a ton of energy
i can tell you put a lot of time in
helping people develop themselves I no
self-esteem and self-confidence was
something I struggled with in my life
but ever since I started developing
myself my life has changed
congratulations do you have a blog i
subscribe for sure i don't really do a
blog but i do a newsletter Christina
let's pop that link up newsletters
awesome I was wondering would you have
any tips for me and my writing skills I
know you're probably busy person but if
you have five minutes I'd really value
your opinion how it could become a
better writer thank you so like anything
else if you want to be a great writer if
you want to be great at whatever you're
doing the number one rule in my mind is
you have to inject passion into it you
know if you're writing there's a lot of
different styles a lot of different
schools of thought there's a lot of
different ways to do it you know I have
my writing style okay I like short I
like punchy I like in your face I like
things that make you think that's my
style it works for me when I'm reading
other people's books or content that's
what I like to read I don't like long
narratives I don't like huge long chunks
of paragraphs I like it short digestible
BAM that's what I like and that's what I
like to write but it's not for everybody
and that's cool for me to start trying
to write a different style wouldn't work
but what works for me is the passion and
that's going to be for for you is going
to be for any writer is passion you've
got to be passionate what you're writing
right look what you write has to be of
extreme importance and one thing I
imagine is you know I want this to be a
legacy for me okay and and this should
be for you like you should be proud of
what you're creating this isn't just
another piece of content that you're
throwing out there and for those you
know who are writers is now that it's
not just another product you're making
not just another service you're making
this is your legacy this is what you're
going to be known for and so you're mean
the process of writing my book right now
I don't want just to be another book I
wanted to be one of the best business
books of all time and so going in with
that approach changes how you write when
I sit down and write my newsletter that
you're going to be a subscriber of now
thank you very much you know I imagined
before I write that somebody that look
up to so I might say okay
today I'm going to imagine that Steve
Jobs going to read my news Oh Donald
Trump was gonna read this newsletter
Richard Branson is going to read this
newsletter auntie Rob is it going to
read this newsletter I imagine that one
of these people are going to read my
newsletter so what's my message you know
it's not just Joe Schmo that I've never
heard of and when you go with that
mindset it increases the importance it
makes it more it makes it more important
for you to create something amazing I
want to write things that my grandkids
will be proud of I want to be able to
show it to them and say look what your
grandfather wrote it's got to be that
important and whatever you do in your
business you have to bring that level of
importance so when you're writing inject
your passion into it make it more
important you're not just writing a
piece of content you're not just writing
a blog you're writing something is going
to change somebody's life it has to be
that important otherwise it's not going
to take off and imagine one of your
mentors whoever it is if you love
self-development maybe it's tony robbins
imagine tony robbins are going to read
your next post how does that change what
you're going to write make it more
important all right next up is Devin
Heiner who wrote in to say hello Evan
thank you for sharing how you have a
humble beginning in the mindset webinar
invite email two days ago I would love
to hear how someone like you who is well
known and established can possibly
manage the over full of information
coming in to your email Cheers Devon boo
email emails a fun question it's not
just emailed social media keeping on top
of everything is tough is challenging
and and so here's how I do it so for
email I get a lot of email my emails on
my website if you go to my about page
you can find my email I'm pretty
accessible guy I have to email inboxes I
have one that is my priority email my
family goes there you know my wife is
there my parents are there my my big
customers are there my important media
contacts it there my movement students
are there Christina pop a link to the
moving program up here that I check at
least once a day
I used to set up so i used to chunk my
time where I have 90 minute chunks I
still do this 90 minute chunks break 90
minute chunk break down a minute chunk
Berg I used to have one chunk every day
just for email and then I decided I'm
going to try to eliminate that chunk on
email and just do email when I have time
and i discovered this i thought about
this when I was that i was grocery
shopping there's a video maybe a shame
we could pop it up here is a video of me
in the grocery store where my least
favorite things grocery shopping and i'm
doing like a selfie on my video camera
i'm talking about my new email strategy
and it's worked and so what I do is
every morning I'll check my priority
email inbox every morning after check my
youtube comments from you guys I check
my priority email and see what has to be
done and it's usually not of a woman
it's usually five to ten minutes of just
checking that email inbox the rest takes
a while and you know when I send out a
newsletter it's going out to almost
100,000 people a lot of people write
back to me and and i love it and it's
awesome and it's great but i don't have
a set time so i'm answering my email on
my phone when i have time and it could
be 1 i'm in the line when i'm at the
dentist when i'm waiting for the my
license plate to be renewed you know
there's a lot of stuff that you do in
your daily life that is that is boring
that you're just waiting there and so
instead of doing you know playing candy
crush or whatever it is i open my email
they start responding to people I don't
have I don't have a data plan so when i
come home at connects to Wi-Fi and sends
them all out and i usually find that
within a week I can catch up and send
Senate the people or if I'm on the
airplane traveling somewhere I load up
my phone quickly answer all the emails
that are outstanding and i usually get
back to most people i try to i'm not
always the greatest but i usually try to
get back I could see it getting to the
point where it's just too overwhelming
too crazy if I can catch up within a
two-week period and i'm not getting back
to people i'll need to give that to my
assistant but I hate I hate having
others talk for me you know I don't
everything on social everything in my
email that's me I may only send you a
smiley face back but that's me doing it
I don't want to
people talking for me and so that's how
I handle it I put the most important
people to my business in my life in one
folder everybody else in the others
those important people get daily
everybody else gets when I have time all
right last up is Natasha who writes in
to say dear Evan how are you doing well
I am fine thank you good to know thank
you so much once again it's always great
to receive your videos and sharing it is
really driven to learning I'm learning a
lot awesome the reason I'm here today is
seeking advice from you i'm looking
forward to start a image consulting
business i'm working on building my
website the window system invest in my
business could you give me advice on how
to write my vision mission statement and
who we are looking forward to hearing
from you soon thank you warm regards
nitesh so nitesh that's a great question
most people's mission vision purpose you
read down on a website you see that okay
you look at a company's mission
statement it's boring it doesn't it
doesn't have passion doesn't inspire
anything look at any any big company
look at their mission a mission is
supposed to be something that wants you
to go drive forward on an important
mission right most people's missions are
super boring they're their corporate
talk most people's values they have a
list of 20 core values I bet if you
asked the CEO of any of these big
companies to list their 20 values they
couldn't name it a lot of it is BS and
what you have to do is make it important
and it starts by making important to you
how I believe is the way to go is you
start around your one word right-
believe you find the one word that means
something to you and figure out why are
you starting this like why do you want
to be an image consultant why is this
important to you tell me a story what
what is the positive change that you
want to make in the world that's what I
want to hear how do you want to make the
world a better place and it doesn't
matter so much about the words that you
use it's more the tone and the passion
coming through if I feel you if I feel
like what you're doing is important to
you then it's going to be a little bit
more important to me your vision well
what do you want the world to look like
how is starting a consulting business
going to change the world for the better
make me feel that tell me why you're
doing this right and you should read
this you should read your mission your
vision your values whatever it is your
one word you should read that and get
excited and get inspired if you read it
and say yeah that's what I do yeah
that's a factual statement of what I do
then you're screwed nobody's going to be
inspired by it if you can't get inspired
by it then how can you expect others to
be inspired by it so write something
that makes you come alive put that into
words and I may not come out perfectly
the first time that's okay you practiced
you get better at it but it's gonna make
you feel a spark to when you see that
you like yes that's what I want to do
because other people who believe in the
same thing you do will be ignited by
that I will want to learn from you and
will want to come to your website and
will want to work with you and want to
spread the word for you so make it
important make it feel something to you
I may be sure when you've done it see if
I feel anything be excited to see any
way that wraps up another edition of the
ask Evan show episode 4 thank you guys
so much for watching you have a question
for me you want me to answer it leave in
the comments below and I'll do my best
make it a good one and you liked this
video you want to see more subscribe to
the channel thank you guys so much for
watching I really appreciate it and I'll
see you soon don't forget to sign up for
my free newsletter its energy in your
inbox every single week hi i'm jason j
reyez fonseka of ra's online com and i
want to say Evan Carmichael's newsletter
is consistent fun inspiring and XD only
newsletter i prioritize and look forward
to period